- You're gonna learn how
to communicate like a CEO
or other top leader.
This is part three in a three-part series
on How to Become a Leader.
And we've now worked our way up
to five ways CEOs communicate
differently than frontline
or even mid-level leaders.
The big overarching skill
that separates top leaders from the rest
is what leadership researcher
Robert Katz describes
as the ability to think and
talk about the big picture.
Compared to frontline
supervisors or mid-level leaders,
leaders at the highest levels must think
and speak about the entire organization.
I'm talking about CEOs, presidents,
the rest of the C-suite.
But even if you're the founder
or owner of a small
business with just a handful
of employees, you must
do these five skills.
Now, as you'll see,
these five big picture communication
skills are more complex
and demanding than most
other communication skills.
Rest assured, anybody can improve
with time, guidance, and effort.
So use this video as a self-assessment
of what skills you're already good at
and the ones you wanna improve.
The number one big picture
way to communicate like a CEO
is to know and communicate
the deeper meaning of work.
Many leaders and authors
call this the why question.
Even before they start an organization,
founding leaders are driven by
a clear purpose, a key reason
for doing what they're doing.
You'll see that spelled
out in their vision
and mission statements and big
goals that they're chasing.
All these help provide the context
and the explanation to help
everybody on the team understand
the deeper meaning of the work.
Now, it's true that some of
those website vision statements
and mission statements sound
like marketing points really,
but I'm talking about
the vision statements
that really hit home.
For example, what's the deeper meaning
that drives the Khan Academy
to keep cranking out educational videos?
The founder, Sal Khan, he has a why
and that is to provide a free
and world class education
to anyone anywhere.
It's his reason for being.
Those employees are not simply
recording and editing videos.
The deeper meaning they all have in mind
is that they wanna educate the
world, and that's powerful.
It's the CEO's job to communicate that.
For our self-assessment,
on a scale of one to 10,
how good are you at seeing
and articulating the big
picture deeper meaning of work?
Top leaders must be
the number one advocate
to communicate the deeper meaning of work.
The number two way that CEOs communicate
is that they must inspire
and motivate others to
achieve great things together.
And we all need individual
inspiration and motivation.
That's true, but the CEO or
the President must get us
to work as one big team together
and show us that we're all part
of something bigger than ourselves.
That's why when JFK gave
his moonshot speech,
he was explicit about who
would be accomplishing this.
He said, "I believe this
nation should commit itself
to achieving the goal
before this decade is out
of landing a man on the moon
and returning him safely to the Earth."
He didn't say, for example,
in my presidency or NASA
or astronauts, he said, "This nation."
He's saying, we, together,
we are going to do this.
Now we create organizations
because individuals can't
do these things alone.
And when Neil Armstrong put
his feet on the moon finally
for the first time before
the end of the decade,
he was speaking from that same mindset.
He didn't even say, "This
is a victory for America."
He said, "It was a
giant leap for mankind."
He was saying, we did this.
And in response, literally,
the entire planet celebrated.
In more everyday, practical ways,
I've heard numerous top leaders inspire
and motivate others to
achieve great things together
by telling success stories
or stories about humble beginnings
and how far we've come together.
I've been working with the president
of a billion dollar company
and he tells stories all
the time about how we,
the company, grew from
less than 25 employees
to over 1,000 employees,
and that each of those employees is part
of that success and legacy.
He doesn't inspire and motivate us
by talking about how he did it.
He talks genuinely
about how we all did it.
Question for you from one to 10,
how good are you at inspiring
and motivating people to work as a team
to achieve great things together?
Now, it's a bonus if you're in
the mid-level management area
or frontline supervisor area,
and you already talk like this,
but top leaders must do it.
Number three is that the CEO must know
and talk about how the various parts
of the organization work together.
Individual contributors in contrast,
talk mostly about their own expertise,
department and division
leaders talk about their shops,
but the top leaders must talk about
how the entire enterprise works together.
Now, maybe that leader
rose through the ranks
and came up through IT
or operations or finance,
but once they're the top
leader, the CEO, the president,
they're now leading all of those areas
and they must talk in ways
that help everybody see the organization
and those different parts
working, coordinating,
and cooperating together.
As organizations grow,
they quickly separate
into what we call silos.
On a farm, you keep the corn in one silo
and the wheat in another
silo so they don't mix.
And that's what happens in organizations.
They silo themselves
and stop sharing information,
resources, talent.
But top leaders know
that organizations work
best when they are running
like interconnected,
interdependent systems
where the subparts talk
to each other more openly
and work together more freely.
Question for you, how skilled are you,
from one to 10, at understanding
and talking about how
all of the various parts
of the organization work together?
The top leaders are really
the only individuals position
for this responsibility,
and that's why they must
be the ones to talk about
how all the parts work together.
Now, I've seen very few popular videos
and mainstream articles written
about the next two CEO
skills, but they're often
what help organizations
succeed in the long run.
Number four is that the CEO must engage
in environmental scanning and sense-making
for their organization.
The first half of this
is what we call environmental scanning.
That's when the top
leaders deliberately look
at external variables that
can influence the organization
like market trends,
government policy changes,
competitors' activities,
innovations and technology changes,
demographic changes, many
other external variables.
They must also track internal variables
like workplace morale and
satisfaction, employee turnover,
and other measures of success.
Top leaders must scan for changes
and then help the organization
adapt to those changes
so they're not caught on their back foot
falling behind the industry.
The second half of environmental
scanning is making sense
of those or interpreting
these factors for employees,
and this should not be
spin or public relations.
The CEO's perspective should be an honest
and helpful sense-making
process of what's happening
around the organization
and in the organization.
Are tariffs going up?
How's that going to affect us?
Another pizza place
opened across the street.
What does that mean for ours?
Three of our top people
left, what do we do now?
From one to 10, how would you
rate yourself in your ability
to scan the environment
and interpret those changes
and how they'll affect your team?
Followers want to hear
what the top leaders
think about those changes,
what they see coming,
and what top leaders plan to do about it.
Number five, CEOs must
communicate effectively
with external stakeholders.
Organizations are not isolated entities.
They are connected to other organizations.
CEOs are positioned at
least at first to work best
with suppliers, vendors, local, federal
and government agencies,
potential partner organizations.
When you see travel websites, for example.
Airlines, hotels, car rental
agencies, all working together,
that's not an accident.
That's the result of top
leaders doing their best
to create collaborative relationships.
Those relationships should
be based on mutual benefits
and a fair exchange of value
between those external stakeholders.
Small organizations do this too,
but in more straightforward ways.
I have a small business that's
wrapped around this channel
where I work with website
people, video, editors,
social media managers,
sponsors, an accounting firm.
I do workshops for client organizations
and coach top corporate leaders.
It's part of my job to
make sure we're all getting
what we want out of these relationships.
From one to 10, how skilled
are you at collaborating
with external stakeholders?
Working with external stakeholders
should elevate everybody's business
and even help you weather
the storms when businesses
are in trouble or things
are not going too well.
That's why it's a necessary
part of the CEO's job
to manage these relationships
as effectively as possible.
Here are the top five communication skills
and responsibilities of CEOs.
Based upon your self-assessment scores,
which of these would you consider
to be the most natural for you
and which of them do you
need the most work on
to gain experience as a leader?
They're all learnable.
Now, since this is part
three of the series,
if you've watched all three
parts, please say hello
and tell me you've
completed the entire series
in a comment below.
And I'll congratulate you
and give you a heart to your comment.
Again, feel free to visit
the free page on my website.
It's a great place to learn
about communication and leadership.
You can start by that class
with the top five essential
communication skills
that all professionals should have.
Until next time, thanks.
God bless and I will see you soon.